parlions du numérique à l'école il y à
quelques instants et bien jardin et
poulaillers ont aussi trouvé leur place
au sein des établissements l'objectif
est bien évidemment est d'éduquer les
enfants aux enjeux environnementaux est
due au développement durable également
sur le département des yvelines la
direction académique des services de
l'éducation nationale soutient cette
ambition elle a labellisé certains
établissements scolaires ceux qui sont
les plus en avance sur ce sujet le
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
dame nord l'anguille et de nicolas
kirillovitch une poule un potager des
outils ce n'est pas encore l'école à la
ferme et on s'y croirait presque pour
les élèves de l'école primaire les
petits près d'elancourt en plus des
habituels mathématiques français
histoire l'environnement s'est fait une
place au sein de l'enseignement à
prendre le cycle de l'oeuf et favoriser
la ponte ont d'ailleurs un intérêt pour
tous on les récolte et après on dirat
métier nous par élève
il ya une seule personne qui ramène à
neuf après il y en a d'autres qui vont
enfin le long débat peut être la poule
est va pondre
donc du coup on va on prend un essai en
leur amène chine promouvoir l'éducation
au développement durable et initier les
plus jeunes aux problématiques
écologiques sont devenus depuis des
années des priorités pour l'éducation
nationale dans les yvelines une
vingtaine d'écoles viennent de recevoir
un label spécial pour les récompenser
dans leurs démarches
ce qui est intéressant c'est aussi de
développer une démarche citoyenne
c'est d'engager ces enfants qui sont les
citoyens de demain de s'approprier des
réflexions
defosse y est c'est à dire que
sur sur le tri de déchets sur le vivre
ensemble sur la consommation ressources
changement climatique ou encore
alimentation les thèmes abordés avec les
écoliers sont variés et complète
l'apprentissage des matières historique
je pourrais citer montaigne par exemple
c'est à dire faire avoir une tête bien
faite plutôt qu'une tête bien pleine
c'est à dire développer d'abord des
méthodes des méthodes de travail et des
méthodes de vide et après bien entendu
basé tout ça sur le cercle vert des
connaissances ce qu'on va apprendre
aussi à l'école pour la nouvelle année
scolaire l'éducation nationale et espère
labellisé une trentaine de nouveaux
établissements dans les yvelines